silver team
on me
talk about getting ready for master
chief because let me just say i really
enjoyed watching you post getting ready
to play master chief yeah it was it was
um you know a long and difficult process
but uh one one that i enjoy i'm
naturally a pretty thin guy um by build
and so to put on and hold
the kind of muscle that i felt was
appropriate for the chief um i had to i
had to eat a lot and i had to lift a lot
of weight and uh and sometimes i put
some pictures on instagram of that yes
folks can go see it it's been documented
it was great documentation
uh the best thing i would say thank my
trainer eddie rayburn who uh is not only
you know the man who helps me build the
muscle but also my personal photographer
oh i love that even more yeah it's sort
of like chef uh taking pictures of the
plate kind of thing i love that um you
get two jobs done you know
yeah
the other thing though too in all
seriousness is it wasn't just physically
getting ready for it i do feel like with
because it's over two decades worth of
time that we've known him through the
games but there's so much that's left
unsaid so
what did you want to bring to the
character because i feel like he's this
ever present thing that everyone knows
about but there's still so many
mysteries surrounding who is master
chief yeah well he's he's a blank slate
you know he's he's a symbol for all of
us uh as players uh when we play halo
he's a symbol for for bravery for
courage for uh effectiveness under
extraordinarily difficult circumstances
um and and we are him when we play the
game you know we we all are asked to uh
go through the halo universe as the
master chief and believe that we're him
and in order to do that he's kept as a
very vague blank slate you know as a
symbol um so there is no character
development there is no you know getting
into his personal feelings or thoughts
or you know how he feels about certain
situations because you're meant to fill
those details in with your own
personality as you play the game and
you're a co-creator of the experience as
a gamer um the medium of television is a
very different one and you're no longer
asked to believe that you're the chief
you're asked to
sit on the couch and and watch our
version of the chief you know and so all
of those things that you filled in with
your own personality we now are filling
in with story and and with um chief's
discovery and john's discovery of who he
is as a human being and that's the
process of our first season is you know
a super soldier who's been uh cut off
from his emotions and and the memories
of his history uh beginning to fill in
uh the the question of of who is the
master chief uh and so you know we as an
audience will discover that along with
john
yeah i like how you're playing i mean we
get some clues throughout the game so
let's just say there's a lot i think
that folks are gonna get to discover but
it sounds to me like this role was made
for you and so real quickly before i get
out of here what was the process of
actually like getting the role because i
would feel like i personally felt that
this was like the pitch perfect casting
but was this something that you went
after as a gamer at heart well no not as
a gamer at heart because i didn't grow
up with tv or video games i had played
the game you know as a teenager but
mostly like at friends houses after
school
but i hadn't ever played campaign or
story mode i'd only played it as a
versus shooter so i was not aware at all
of uh you know the amount and the depth
of the mythology and the story that had
already been created for the game so
that that was the my process of
discovery when i got the job was really
just an eye-opening experience of
realizing how much had already been
created how deep and rich it was um
so
so that's that's been the process for me
so far and
just feeling really extraordinarily
lucky
you know that i get to do this that i
get to be a part of such a deep and rich
and big community that is so excited for
this
process to finally
come to fruition and for halo to be on
their screens because they've waited for
a long time we've all waited for a long
time for this to happen so really
feeling quite lucky and yeah it does
feel like a really good match of of
character and actor you know i think a
lot of the stuff that i've done in the
past has kind of led me up to this
moment with uh 13 hours and den of
thieves kind of being really good
preparation particularly for for this
role um but many other things i've done
the past that that are quite different
from this also led me here you know and
it's one of my real goals as an actor is
to stretch myself in as many different
directions as possible as i can while i
am lucky enough to be in this position
and this feels like one particularly
strong
direction to get to push myself in
[Music]
here's lethal
upgradeable
and most importantly
erin
controllable
going to start with you because what's
so interesting with your character is
it's new to the universe and we're
really getting to explore the various
things that we didn't necessarily get to
pull from the game and i'm just curious
like did you
did you finally decide to get past level
two have you made it
everyone keeps asking me this i need
tips i need someone to guide me i can't
do it on my own
i have it no i haven't you give her any
tips because i would imagine being
literally
pulled literally from the game and
dragged all the way into this series
i'm just kidding now uh did you have to
like come and give everyone like tip
tips and pointers like this is what you
guys need to know oh they would love
that if i did that yeah that would be
very well received
i did not do anything like that no i
think um i'm the baby on this show i
mean because i have done very little
television i've done just small amounts
of it so
yeah so so we're the babies
i feel that but seriously though i feel
like kwon's character there is an
entirely different feel to the series
because of her inclusion what
particularly did you want to
bring to this character because it is
such a blank slate in the sense that you
could do so much with it as it didn't
have so much lore coming into it
um i guess i wanted to
create her as a way for the audience's
eye in especially for the new audiences
because
you know i remember otto
the director being like you're
experiencing everything for the first
time like quan is experiencing
everything for the first time and i hope
that the new fans will also feel that
and i feel like with her inclusion in it
it will bring
that new audience and being able to
understand everything that she's also
going through at the same time
um and
also i guess just in terms of like
those themes of like empathy and kind of
you know
those human emotions that we we don't
really get to see master chief with in
the games i think um
we bring a lot more sense of like a
personal story um
with her inclusion into the series
yeah yeah no i think both of your
inclusion adds so much to what master
chief the character is able to do
throughout the series again i haven't
seen that much from what i can but what
i know from the games and then also from
what i've seen i feel like you both are
going to be such formidable influences
and jen i heard that you got to do a
little bit of voice capture
with pablo and so i'm just curious what
that was like i mean i feel in a voice
capture studio you have to feel like all
right i got this i could show him what's
up
now i've never felt that with pablo no
pablo's pablo's the pro man he is the
pro
no i did yeah i did some uh motion cap
we did motion capture to i did well i
was doing motion capture and the first
step we did he was just walking around
in his jeans in a sweatshirt
yeah
yeah and he's like sandal-y thing yeah
yeah
um so
yeah so uh we he didn't he didn't have
to do any motion capture oh man
at least he got to enjoy you and your
element how about that i do i do dig
that very much and honestly i'm so glad
you're included as a person that played
the game i could not imagine anybody
else's voice so thank you jacqueline i'm
thrilled to be here
ah me too sorry i just love hearing you
talk you just decided to help me why
wouldn't spartan do that
what does one do with a superhuman
you're not sure you can
trust hello master chief
i'm cortana
both of you thank you so much and
congratulations on this series i have to
kind of ask both of you and natasha i'll
start with you
when you read the script for this
what really sort of jumped out about it
that made you want to jump into it
because let's be honest it's not exactly
the most approachable material unless
you're like a heavy gamer no it's a very
good point um and i think that's
actually what made me reticent about
drilling into it i i read it a few times
and i thought well this isn't really
rocking my boat
and then i met up with um the guy who
was
otto who was
directing the first episode and i mean
also to be fair the the script was in a
very different incarnation than the one
that we ended up shooting so it was
really a sort of road map as to
introducing the world and the characters
and i did some research then around the
cannon and around the game and the sort
of legacy of that and how you know we
would be building upon that and
departing from that but also being you
know reverential towards it and i
thought oh great so we've got history
here and we're creating something new um
i'm in this is very exciting and we were
dealing with a lot of the themes that
i'm very interested in um anyway and i
liked with all good sci-fi hopefully
there usually is a philosophical basis
to it um
and um i'd done a couple of sci-fi's
before and i've read stanislav
that you know
gone into that space before so it's um
not totally unfamiliar and ai as well
getting an opportunity to yeah explore
that extensively was really interesting
uh so yeah there was tons of um tons of
directions in which it pulled me in yeah
yeah and then olive i'll kind of tweak
it a bit with you because what i really
loved about your character is she kind
of has the heart of a rebel but she's
working for i guess you would want to
say like the empire as it were
and then on the other side with your
character natasha she feels she's a
rebel but she's like more about it than
anyone else so yeah olive what about
that did that jump out from you by the
time you were able to to be in the part
of the script or was that something that
came through the evolution of the
character that was actually like the
first
kind of
thing that drew me in was
i think i'm all about
uh i don't know what the word would be i
guess like juxtapositions things things
that work against one another um and i
think it's so fascinating playing
somebody who has
a real rebel's heart within a world that
is is is something else i actually
would
personally say that halsey
has that in the exact same measure but
in just a very different way
um
but i think that
for miranda it's probably easier to see
because it's it's from a standpoint of
compassion a deep kind of compassion for
human beings and for what she believes
um
is morally right from the standpoint of
really an emotional
outlook on the world and i think that
actually um
as olive i i think that uh
in order to create change
you need
people
everyone can't look the same you know
and i think that that's something that's
being uh shown in the world today you
know if if everyone is just the activist
that's going out on the streets where
are the people who are working within
legislation if everyone's working within
legislation where are the people who are
you know doing it another way people
speaking to their family and their
friends i think that there need to be
there are so many aspects and avenues
with which to evoke change and i think
all of them need to be uh
explored by different people and so i
think that as much as
change
needs to happen from the standpoint of
somebody who is
looking at it from maybe a slightly more
clinical outlook and looking at the big
picture rather than you know the people
who might the collateral damage i think
that it's equally important to have
someone like miranda who is deeply
feeling about the immediate damage and
the immediate pain and the immediate
hurt that is happening kind of on the
ground um
within the process of creating that
change
[Applause]
humans
surrender to the covenant
cortana i'm gonna need you now i wanted
to start with how you all decided to
craft this particular version of halo
most specifically the suit as that is
such an iconic part of the sort of halo
universe yeah i mean i think um the the
broader question of just um uh crafting
the overall story um was really about
um being able to tell a character story
around master chief and john and you
know we have this universe which has
this epic sci-fi backdrop and and this
this alien human conflict and humanity
at stake and so those pieces
um we knew we would bring in but in
telling john's story you know that's
really where where steve sort of took
um took it from there i mean that the
the origin of him was important to the
journey but i steve really crafted
um crafted that that journey
yeah we wanted to uh tell a human story
and tell john's story
and pull from canon elaborate on canon
give people a sense of what the if
you're
absolutely
new to halo
give you that sense of the history and
if you're a longtime halo
aficionado you get to see stuff that
you've read about in other other media
and uh just tell a human story that
would be compelling on its own and then
just put it in this amazing world that
you know halo spent 20 years building
um both in scale and scope and also just
in terms of the the characters and the
and the themes of you know that make it
special and the armor to your point yeah
and the armor incredible process right
and you know with each game we go
through tweaks with the armor there's
actually a number of different sort of
generations of armor
um and so this is its own generation
they always sort of come from the same
place but i think what was so
interesting about the process
is
um while we built armor physical armor
before with our battle scenes and our
action scenes this was so so much
took so much of a harder toll on the
armor
and we discovered there's all sorts of
things that are super easy for us to do
in the games because we can cheat we can
cheat collision cheat collisions and you
know how things you know how the engine
or engine how the rifle bud fits in um
in the real world those things actually
don't work
yeah quite the same way yeah even being
able to reach and get the gun is a
challenge um and the armor weighs like
50 pounds right so these these
guys and gals are running around in 50
pounds of armor that also is you know
not fragile but is physical and so i i
was saying that after every battle scene
it looked like like a car crash like
there's just
everywhere and well one of the people
that fits out that armor very
particularly well is pablo just because
of what he brings not only to the
character but to its physical stature if
you guys could just real quick tell me
why you knew that he'd be the perfect
person to embody essentially everyone's
avatar throughout the halo world it's a
very intimate sort of relationship with
the gamers and stephen i'll start with
you well his was one of the first
audition tapes i mean if you want to
call that that i saw and i immediately
was drawn to it because i was a fan
since i mean the wire when he was just a
young guy and uh starting out and just
followed his career he brings to the
role not just great physicality and
control of his body and and size and
strength um he also has this depth that
he his face just evokes you know you see
that there's a he's not just sort of a
hero type he's he's got that
vulnerable quality to him that he brings
to it so we thought he was a great blend
of sort of strength and yet at the same
time
soul and and and we knew that if we
hitched our wagon to that and had the
audience sort of
identify with him in his journey that he
would bring us in that place and give us
the full gamut of emotions and at the
same time be this
this hero that people expect from master
chief
you